bonsoir philippe emmanuelli merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france une campagne de vaccination
dès janvier dans treize mille centres
répartis à travers la péninsule
c'est une étape qui vous paraît crédible
selon vous oui en tout cas et de
ressentis chaise a clairement affiché sa
volonté d'être un des premiers pays
européens à faire bénéficier l'espagne
de la vaccination
alors effectivement cet effet
d'affichage a déjà pris a déjà été
modérée il ya 24 heures puisque
aujourd'hui on parle de vacciner à peu
près 5% de la population espagnole entre
janvier et fin mars
donc on voit bien que effectivement ce
programme de vaccination va s'étaler
vraisemblablement jusqu'en 2022 alors
comment ça va ce prix ionisé en espagne
en entendu le président écran dire qu'en
france ça sera les plus fragiles comment
s'organisent les choses sur place chez
vous alors sur place le comité chargé de
l'organisation de la vaccination en
espagne a défini un camembert avec 18 18
si vous voulez catégories de population
cible à vacciner donc évidemment ça va
commencer par les populations les plus à
risque c'est-à-dire comme comme on
pouvait l'entendre dans votre sujet par
les personnes institutionnalisé en
maison de retraite et les personnels de
santé ainsi que les personnes
handicapées mais 18 catégories ont été
définies ci pour étaler le plan de
vaccination dans le temps est-ce que
vous dr emmanuelli en tant que médecin
vous êtes en constance parce qu on
entend certains détracteurs dire ok
c'est bien c'est ces annonces mais pour
l'instant ce ne sont que des effets
d'annoncé surtout des communiqués on n'a
pas vraiment eu les détails d'une étude
scientifique rigoureuse derrière vous
vous êtes en confiance en tant que
médecin sur l'efficacité de ces vaccins
et notamment le fait de les pratiquer
sur les populations par définition les
plus fragiles en premier lieu oui je
crois que que vous soulignez
parfaitement quel est l'enjeu de cette
vaccination et le débat qui va
nécessairement s'ouvrir dans les médias
dans les milieux scientifiques et dans
la population en général je dois vous
avouer qu'en ce qui me concerne je suis
un médecin généraliste
j'allais dire classique c'est à dire qui
est favorable d'une façon générale aux
vaccinations parce qu'on sait que ces
vaccinations ont permis d'éradiquer un
certain nombre de fléaux mondiaux
pour autant je ne je ne peux
effectivement que comme simple citoyen
comme évoque comme patient éventuel
m'interroger sur la fiabilité des
vaccins à venir qui vont être les
premiers vaccins est reproduit dans ce
laps de temps aussi court et qui surtout
font appel à de nouvelles technologies
que ce soit le vaccin à rennes messager
de modena outsider ou le vaccin
d'ailleurs d'astrazeneca qui va recourir
effectivement un virus du rhume du
chimpanzé pour faire pénétrer les
antigènes du virus certains certaines
portions d'antigènes les virus pour
déclencher la production d'anticorps
donc c'est vrai que nécessairement il va
falloir effectivement lire avec beaucoup
d'attention les études qui vont être
publié dans les prochains jours ainsi
que les avis qu'ils vont être émis par
les hautes autorités de santé dont c'est
la responsabilité de nous indiquer quel
est le réel
ratio bénéfice risque de ces vaccins à
venir en tout cas l'espagne souffre du
même scepticisme que la france puisque
selon une étude réalisée le 30 octobre
le journal el país près de six personnes
sur dix vivent en espagne pense que
d'une manière ou d'une autre je cite le
vaccin contre le coc vite cache une
conspiration quelconque
comment vous vous l'expliquer oui
écouter tout cela survient au décours
d'une épidémie unique et dans l'histoire
de notre génération et c'est vrai que
les hésitations les messages
contradictoires qui ont émaillé le
développement cette épidémie on se
souvient de la polémique des masques on
se souvient la polémique sur le
confinement on se souvient des allers
retours des différents gouvernements sur
les mesures à mettre en oeuvre ont rendu
méfiant la population est aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que l'idée d'un vaccin qui
serait élaborée dans la précipitation et
bien éveil la même méfiance
on sait qu'il ya aussi des vaccins voilà
on réussit à 95 % d'efficacité selon les
autorités le vaccin chinois qui est déjà
utilisée par exemple à à dubaï en l'émir
même s'est fait vacciner est ce qu'il y
a quelque chose d'extrêmement politique
dans ces vaccins et peut-on finalement
le le regretté que tel ou tel pays pour
des raisons peut-être idéologique
n'utilise pas tel ou tel vaccin
vrai vous avez raison n'échappons pas à
l'effet d'affichage politique des
différents gouvernements qui aujourd'hui
ne souhaite qu'une chose c'est une sorte
de happy end
après cette annus horribilis de
l'épidémie par le cos vide et donc tout
le monde évidemment souhaite grandir
la fin de la partie en sortant le vaccin
qui doit effectivement régler
définitivement la question de cette
épidémie
mais aujourd'hui tout le monde partage
les mêmes interrogations c'est à dire
quelle sera la durée d'immunité que
conférera ce vaccin à partir de quel
moment pour on pourra t'on vraiment
s'assurer que ces vaccins ne peuvent pas
produire d'effets indésirables à moyen
terme
c'est le véritable enjeu aujourd'hui est
derrière cet affichage politique
et bien il y aura peut-être des comptes
à rendre si tout est fait si certaines
choses sont faites dans la précipitation
en tout cas en france emmanuel macron
invité le vaccin ne sera pas obligatoire
qu'en est-il en espagne eh bien écoutez
pour le moment il n'y a pas eu d'annoncé
aussi clair en espagne on sait pas si
cette vaccination va être rendu
obligatoire au nom en espagne merci
beaucoup en tout cas philippe emmanueli
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france pour nous parler de la situation
sanitaire en espagne